This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. I'm sorry. It's one of the simplest things to say, and also one of the hardest. That's especially true when we're apologizing to the most important people in our lives. When we've wronged a parent or a partner or a close friend, working up the courage to make a man's
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。对不起。这是最简单却也最难说出口的话之一。当我们向生命中最重要的人道歉时，尤其如此。当我们伤害了父母、伴侣或挚友，鼓起勇气去弥补
can sometimes feel really hard. or a partner or a close friend, working up the courage to make amends can sometimes feel really hard. Why is that? Why do many of us find it difficult to apologize, especially to the people we love? Last week on the show, we explored the psychology of forgiveness. This week on Hidden Brain,
有时会感觉非常困难。或者伴侣或挚友，鼓起勇气去弥补有时会感觉非常困难。这是为什么呢？为什么我们许多人觉得道歉很难，尤其是对我们所爱的人？上周的节目中，我们探讨了宽恕的心理学。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，
the psychology of apologizing. We on Hidden Brain, the psychology of apologizing. We look at the mental barriers that make it hard for us to acknowledge when we've done something wrong, the changing cultural expectations around apologies, and why it may be useful to think of an apology as a gift. Did you apologize? At the University of Queensland in Australia, Tyler Okimoto studies the psychology of apologies. He examines what happens in our minds when we apologize, when we don't, and the transformative power of apologies. Tyler Okimoto, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you Shankar, glad to be here.
道歉的心理学。在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们探讨道歉的心理学。我们审视那些让我们难以承认自己做错事的心理障碍，围绕道歉不断变化的文化期望，以及为什么把道歉视为一份礼物是有益的。你道歉了吗？在澳大利亚昆士兰大学，泰勒·奥基莫托研究道歉的心理学。他审视当我们道歉或不道歉时，我们内心发生了什么，以及道歉所具有的变革力量。泰勒·奥基莫托，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，尚卡尔，很高兴来到这里。
I want to take you back Tyler to the 2016 Rio Olympics, the star US swimmer Ryan Lockty and one other athlete, said they had been robbed at night by armed men. It turned out the story was only a cover for what really happened and that this is a classic example of how we often react when we're accused of doing something bad. Yeah, that's right, that's right. First reaction is, deny, come up with an excuse, trying to paint yourself in the best possible picture. And it turned out what had actually happened
泰勒，我想带你回到2016年里约奥运会，美国游泳明星瑞安·洛赫特和其他一名运动员声称他们在夜间遭到武装人员抢劫。事实证明，这个故事只是掩盖真相的幌子，这是我们被指控做坏事时通常反应的典型例子。是的，没错，没错。第一反应是否认，找借口，试图把自己描绘成最好的形象。结果发现实际发生的是
is that he had been drinking, been partying, had thrown a tantrum in the store, had done some property damage, and the security guard had tried to intervene and stop the behavior and Lock the realizing that this was going to be a PR problem for him Invented the story put out a statement in expectation that something negative was gonna come out about him And it was only with hindsight and time that he was actually able to step up and own up to the fact that he'd blatantly lied
他喝了酒，参加了派对，在店里大发脾气，造成了一些财产损失，保安试图干预并阻止这种行为。洛赫特意识到这会给他带来公关问题，于是编造了这个故事，并发表了一份声明，预料到会有负面消息传出。直到事后回顾和经过一段时间，他才真正能够站出来，承认自己公然撒谎的事实。
So in some ways this is the adult version of, you know, the dog ate my homework. I want to talk about one other incident, Tyler, which I think really reveals the power of what happens when apologies go off the rails. In April 2010, an oil rig exploded in the Gulf of Mexico. It killed 11 workers. It ignited a fireball that was visible 40 miles away. This was the infamous Deepwater Horizon oil spill. The rig was leased by BP,
所以在某种程度上，这是“狗吃了我的作业”的成人版。泰勒，我想谈谈另一件事，我认为这真正揭示了道歉偏离轨道时所发生事情的力量。2010年4月，墨西哥湾的一个石油钻井平台发生爆炸。它造成11名工人死亡。它引发的火球在40英里外都能看到。这就是臭名昭著的“深水地平线”漏油事件。该钻井平台由英国石油公司（BP）租赁，
one of the largest oil companies in the world. Here's how BP responded according to news reports. Almost from the moment on April 20th, that oil began fouling the Gulf BP seemed to view the disaster through rose-colored glasses. May 13th, Chairman Tony Hayward, speaking to the Guardian newspaper. The Gulf of Mexico is a very big ocean,
全球最大的石油公司之一。根据新闻报道，BP的反应如下。几乎从4月20日石油开始污染海湾的那一刻起，BP似乎就戴着有色眼镜看待这场灾难。5月13日，董事长托尼·海沃德在接受《卫报》采访时说。墨西哥湾是一个非常大的海洋，
the volume of oil and dispersant were putting into it as tiny in relation to the total water volume. Five days later, Hayward again, to Britain's sky news, I think the environmental impact of this disaster is likely to be very modest. The Gulf of Mexico is a very big ocean. Tyler, what do you hear in BP's response? Well, it's a bit of a ryan locked you on the bigger scale, right? It sounds like the initial responses do seem to be about minimizing the damage. I actually remember Tony Hayward's apology quite vividly. I was living in the state of the time and I turned to my wife after watching the commercial that BP put on television,
我们投入其中的石油和分散剂的体积相对于总水量来说微不足道。五天后，海沃德再次对英国天空新闻台说，我认为这场灾难对环境的影响很可能是非常温和的。墨西哥湾是一个非常大的海洋。泰勒，你在BP的回应中听到了什么？嗯，这在更大范围内有点像瑞安·洛赫特事件，对吧？听起来最初的反应似乎都是为了尽量减少损失。我实际上非常生动地记得托尼·海沃德的道歉。当时我住在那个州，在看了BP在电视上播放的广告后，我转向我的妻子，
where I remember seeing it live, and turning to her and saying, oh, this looks like a PR stunt, it's not going to go well. So the CEO, Tony Hayward initially said, it was maybe a thousand barrels a day that was flooding into the ocean, but at its peak, it turns out there were 60,000 barrels a day flooding into the ocean, which is really a huge difference. And again, as people heard this, I think they heard exactly what you just said, which is that BP was trying to minimize the extent of the damage.
我记得当时是现场直播，我转向她说，哦，这看起来像是一场公关噱头，不会有好结果的。所以首席执行官托尼·海沃德最初说，每天流入海洋的石油可能是一千桶，但事实证明，在高峰期，每天有6万桶石油流入海洋，这确实是一个巨大的差异。同样，当人们听到这个消息时，我想他们听到的正是你刚才所说的，即BP试图尽量减少损害程度。
Yeah, yeah, that's right. And while I might try to give Tony Hayward the benefit of the doubt, and that maybe he didn't have all the information, and maybe that statement was to the best of his knowledge, you know, it is a bit difficult to swallow an error of 60 fold. So it just seems like immediate reaction seemed to be more concerned with reassuring the company of what was happening rather than necessarily thinking about what the public actually wanted from that situation. I want to play you another clip of the next aspect of the BP Deepwater spill saga when a reporter confronted Tony Hayward. Here's what he said.
是的，是的，没错。虽然我可能会试着给托尼·海沃德留有余地，也许他没有掌握所有信息，也许那份声明是他所知范围内的最好情况，你知道，要接受60倍的误差确实有点困难。所以看起来他的直接反应似乎更关心安抚公司正在发生的事情，而不是思考公众在那种情况下真正想要什么。我想给你播放另一段关于BP深水地平线漏油事件后续的片段，当时一名记者质问托尼·海沃德。他是这样说的。
There's no one who wants this thing over more than I do. I'd like my life back. So there's no one who wants this thing done more than I do. There's just no effort being spared in any dimension. So Hay what says I'd like my life back. And I'm sure that was the case. I'm sure he wasn't having a good time while this was unfolding. But it does sound like he was seeing the problem through the lens of his own self-pity. Yeah, that's right. I think there was a collective grown across the entire PR world when he said that. I can understand kind of what he was trying to get across. He's trying to show that he's empathizing, that I understand the pain, I'm
没有人比我更想结束这件事。我想找回我的生活。所以没有人比我更想完成这件事。在任何方面都没有节省任何努力。所以海沃德说我想找回我的生活。我相信确实如此。我相信他在事情展开时过得并不好。但这听起来确实像是他通过自怜的视角来看待这个问题。是的，没错。我想当他说出那句话时，整个公关界都发出了一阵集体呻吟。我可以理解他试图表达的意思。他试图表现出他在共情，我理解这种痛苦，我
feeling it too. But the way that he said it and the timing with which he said it really made it come off as really I'm the one suffering here. And he seemed to be more concerned with his own experience. We've seen how our initial response to our own wrongdoing is often marked by denial, minimization, and self-pity. These responses often produce an unintended consequence. They make the victims of our wrongdoing furious. Here is a Gulf Coast resident responding to Tony Hayward and BP. If you care, stop the oral from coming into our estuaries.
也感同身受。但他说话的方式和时机确实让人觉得，真正受苦的是我。他似乎更关心自己的经历。我们已经看到，我们对自己不当行为的最初反应往往以否认、最小化和自怜为特征。这些反应往往会产生意想不到的后果。它们让我们的受害者感到愤怒。这是一位墨西哥湾沿岸居民对托尼·海沃德和BP的回应。如果你在乎，就停止石油流入我们的河口。
If you care, I don't think you do care. I think you care about your image. You don't care about us. Now, it's possible that people would have been furious, regardless of what BP did. The spill went on to be one of the worst in history. Hundreds of thousands of marine animals were killed. But Tyler says that BP's response not only didn't help, but may actually have made things worse. When you feel victimized, and then somebody's response to that
如果你在乎，我不认为你在乎。我认为你在乎的是你的形象。你不在乎我们。现在，无论BP做什么，人们可能都会感到愤怒。这次漏油事件后来成为历史上最严重的事件之一。成千上万的海洋动物死亡。但泰勒说，BP的反应不仅没有帮助，反而可能让事情变得更糟。当你感到受害，然后某人对此的反应
is insufficient, it can really compound the negative feeling as a consequence of that. So it feels rather than just an accident, this is an accident that nobody actually cared about, that there is no remorse. That makes it just that much worse. [♪ Music playing in background, playing in background,
是不充分的，这真的会加剧负面情绪。所以感觉这不仅仅是一场事故，而是一场没人真正在乎的事故，没有任何悔意。这让情况变得更糟。[♪ 背景音乐播放，背景音乐播放，
as Ryan Lockty discovered, there is a very high cost to not getting apologies right. Three months after the rig exploded, Tony Hayward was forced to resign as CEO. BP's public image took a beating. Coming up, saying I'm sorry is one of the first things parents teach their children. So why is it so hard for grown-ups to apologize? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We all do things we regret or wish we could undo.
正如瑞安·洛赫特所发现的那样，道歉不当的代价非常高昂。钻井平台爆炸三个月后，托尼·海沃德被迫辞去首席执行官职务。BP的公众形象受到了打击。接下来，说“对不起”是父母教给孩子的第一件事之一。那么为什么成年人道歉这么难呢？你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。我们都会做一些后悔或希望可以撤销的事情。
And we all know how tempting it can be to deny the harm we've done or shift blame to someone else, even though this can often make things worse. Psychologist Tyler Okimoto of the University of Queensland in Australia has studied why it's so difficult for us to admit we've done something wrong and then to apologize. Tyler, you've looked at what happens when people do something wrong and then refuse to say they're sorry, tell me about the studies you've conducted and how refusing to apologize can affect people's self-esteem. Well, I think we've probably all experienced the urge to not apologize.
我们都知道否认我们造成的伤害或将责任推给别人是多么诱人，尽管这往往会让事情变得更糟。澳大利亚昆士兰大学的心理学家泰勒·奥基莫托研究了为什么我们如此难以承认自己做错了事，然后道歉。泰勒，你研究过当人们做错事然后拒绝道歉时会发生什么，告诉我你进行的研究，以及拒绝道歉如何影响人们的自尊。嗯，我想我们可能都经历过不想道歉的冲动。
One of the things that happens when you apologize is actually you are relinquishing a bit of power and control in that situation by admitting that you've done something wrong, by saying that you're sorry in a way you're handing over the opportunity for forgiveness to the other person. So it's no longer in my control to decide whether or not I'm a person of good moral standing. It's now in your hands for you to decide whether or not I'm worthy of forgiveness. And tell me about the experiments that you've done that have explored this idea, the experiments that have looked at both the issues of control and the issue of self-esteem. So we conducted a series of experiments to really try to understand the psychological experience of refusing to apologize. What we found was actually
当你道歉时，发生的一件事实际上是你放弃了一点权力和控制权，通过承认你做错了事，通过说你很抱歉，在某种程度上，你把宽恕的机会交给了对方。所以，决定我是否是一个道德高尚的人不再由我控制。现在掌握在你手中，由你来决定我是否值得被宽恕。告诉我你所做的探索这个想法的实验，那些研究了控制权和自尊问题的实验。所以我们进行了一系列实验，试图真正理解拒绝道歉的心理体验。我们发现实际上
quite interesting when people came forward and essentially said that I do not apologize for what I've done. It actually resulted in a short-term boost in their reported self-esteem. They actually felt better about themselves following a refusal to apologize. Now, what we did in the research is really tried to understand why that boost occurred. And what we found was that when you've refused to apologize, it gives you a bit of a feeling of increased power and control in that situation. And at the same time, by digging in and saying, no, no, I've done the right thing. It actually gives a bit of a boost to your feelings of integrity as well. If you think about integrity, integrity is walking your talk when you apologize you're
非常有趣，当人们站出来基本上说我不为我所做的事情道歉时。这实际上导致了他们报告的自尊心在短期内有所提升。在拒绝道歉后，他们实际上对自己感觉更好。现在，我们在研究中所做的是真正试图理解为什么会出现这种提升。我们发现，当你拒绝道歉时，它会让你在那种情况下有一种权力感和控制感增强的感觉。与此同时，通过坚持己见并说，不，不，我做了正确的事。它实际上也提升了你的正直感。如果你考虑正直，正直就是言行一致，当你道歉时，你
saying the way that I acted is not consistent with my values and refusing to apologize really digs in and so has that short term beneficial effect to how you feel about yourself. Now you can draw the wrong conclusion here. Tyler is not saying it's a good thing to refuse to apologize. He's explaining why refusing to apologize can give you a short term boost. When I first feature Tyler's research on NPR's morning edition, conservative talk show host Drush Limbaugh picked up on the story. One of the researchers, Tyler Okimoto, explained his interpretation of the result this way. So when you refuse to apologize, it actually makes you feel more empowered. It makes you feel more dominant.
是在说我的行为方式与我的价值观不一致，而拒绝道歉确实坚持了这一点，因此对你的自我感觉产生了短期的有益影响。现在你可能会得出错误的结论。泰勒并不是说拒绝道歉是一件好事。他是在解释为什么拒绝道歉会给你带来短期的提升。当我第一次在NPR的《早间版》节目中介绍泰勒的研究时，保守派脱口秀主持人拉什·林博报道了这个故事。其中一位研究人员泰勒·奥基莫托这样解释他对结果的解读。所以当你拒绝道歉时，它实际上让你感到更有力量。它让你感到更占主导地位。
It makes you feel less subservient. It makes you feel not guilty. As a professional broadcaster, I can tell you that there is an adage. Don't care what you do, don't ever apologize. And it was actually quite interesting. My mother called me and said that my aunt had heard about my research on the radio and was so proud of me. And I said, oh, I didn't know that she listened to NPR. And it turns out it wasn't the NPR interview, it was Rich Limbaugh. So in some ways, what I hear you saying is that when we justify our behavior, it allows us in some ways to maintain our positive self-concept.
它让你感到不那么卑微。它让你感到没有罪恶感。作为一名专业广播员，我可以告诉你有一句格言。不管你做什么，永远不要道歉。这实际上非常有趣。我母亲打电话给我说，我阿姨在收音机里听到了我的研究，并为我感到骄傲。我说，哦，我不知道她听NPR。结果发现那不是NPR的采访，而是拉什·林博。所以在某种程度上，我听到你说的是，当我们为自己的行为辩护时，它在某种程度上允许我们维持我们积极的自我概念。
In some ways, it's acting almost like armor. Now admittedly this armor might slow us down, it might prevent us from doing some things, but the impulse to dodge might actually come from this perhaps understandable desire to protect our self-concept. That's right. In the face of a threat, our natural psychological reaction is to protect the self. The challenge then is that our self-concept is also not just about who we are as individuals, but also our relationships and how we engage with other people and who we are as a group member and our immediate reaction to protect our self, our personal self, sometimes comes at a cost of our social self and our relationships. I want to play you a clip that I came by recently. The TV talk show host Ellen DeGeneres came on the fire some time ago for presiding over what some employees called a toxic workplace.
在某种程度上，它几乎像盔甲一样起作用。虽然不可否认，这种盔甲可能会减慢我们的速度，可能会阻止我们做一些事情，但回避的冲动实际上可能来自这种或许可以理解的保护自我概念的愿望。是的，没错。面对威胁时，我们自然的心理反应是保护自我。那么挑战在于，我们的自我概念不仅关乎我们作为个体是谁，还关乎我们的人际关系，我们如何与他人互动，以及我们作为群体成员是谁，而我们保护自我、个人自我的直接反应有时是以牺牲我们的社会自我和人际关系为代价的。我想给你播放一段我最近看到的片段。电视脱口秀主持人艾伦·德杰尼勒斯前段时间因为主持了一些员工所说的有毒工作场所而受到抨击。
Here's a clip of Ellen talking about these charges on the today show. I am a kind person. I am a person who likes to make people happy. I am a people pleaser. You know, this is who I am. And so when I started hearing, you know, reading ridiculous things, and then it just kept going and going and going and going. That made me think someone's trying to really hurt me. And then right on the heels of that, I read in the press that there's a toxic work environment, which I mean, I had no idea. So we talked a second ago about how we sometimes build up armor to protect our self-concept.
这是艾伦在《今日秀》上谈论这些指控的片段。我是一个善良的人。我是一个喜欢让人们快乐的人。我是一个讨好他人的人。你知道，这就是我。所以当我开始听到，你知道，读到荒谬的事情时，然后它就一直持续下去。这让我觉得有人真的想伤害我。紧接着，我在媒体上读到有一个有毒的工作环境，我的意思是，我根本不知道。所以我们刚才谈到了我们有时如何建立盔甲来保护我们的自我概念。
But I want to explore the idea that one reason apologizing can be hard is because in some ways we have a self-concept that is very positive. Now, Ellen has disputed some of the charges made about her workplace and I don't want to get into who's right or what happened in this particular workplace. But for our purposes here, I'm struck by her language. She's telling us, I'm a kind person, I'm a people pleaser. How could I possibly have presided over a toxic workplace? Is it possible, Taya, that in some ways our positive self-concept itself can become a barrier to apologizing?
但我想要探讨一个想法，即道歉之所以困难的一个原因是，在某种程度上，我们有一个非常积极的自我概念。现在，艾伦对关于她工作场所的一些指控提出过异议，我不想深入探讨谁是对的或在这个特定的工作场所发生了什么。但为了我们这里的目的，她的语言让我印象深刻。她告诉我们，我是一个善良的人，我是一个讨好他人的人。我怎么可能主持了一个有毒的工作场所？泰勒，有没有可能在某种程度上，我们积极的自我概念本身就成了道歉的障碍？
Yeah, absolutely. We get through life functionally because we can think about ourselves in a positive way. And that is part of who we are. A parallel that I like to talk about when I'm teaching is the idea of being a good leader. So I think of myself as a good leader, but good leaders actually sit back, reflect, and think about when they haven't been a good leader. What makes a good leader is somebody who's reflective. Same sort of situation here. Being a moral person is about being able to stop, reflect on your behavior and come to a judgment about whether or not what you've done is reflective of who you want to be and what your values are. And when that break is there, when there's a gap, being a moral person is about acknowledging that and apologizing if that's appropriate.
是的，绝对。我们之所以能功能性地度过一生，是因为我们可以以积极的方式思考自己。这是我们的一部分。我在教学时喜欢谈论的一个类比是成为一名好领导者的想法。所以我认为自己是一名好领导者，但好领导者实际上会坐下来，反思并思考他们什么时候没有成为一名好领导者。好领导者是善于反思的人。这里也是同样的情况。做一个有道德的人就是能够停下来，反思自己的行为，并对你所做的事情是否反映了你想成为的人以及你的价值观做出判断。当那个断层存在时，当有差距时，做一个有道德的人就是承认这一点，并在适当的时候道歉。
It's interesting then that when people are justifying their behavior, I mean, it sounds like they're justifying their behavior to us, but it seems to me that it's also possible then that they're actually justifying their behavior to us, but it seems to me that it's also possible that they're actually justifying their behavior to themselves. Yeah, that's right. When we're being threatened, when we're being questioned, we try to defend our self-esteem because we don't want to feel bad about ourselves,
那么有趣的是，当人们为自己的行为辩护时，我的意思是，听起来他们是在向我们辩护，但对我来说，似乎也有可能他们实际上是在向我们辩护，但对我来说，似乎也有可能他们实际上是在向自己辩护。是的，没错。当我们受到威胁，当我们受到质疑时，我们试图捍卫我们的自尊，因为我们不想对自己感觉不好，
nobody likes feeling bad on an ongoing basis. And then when given the opportunity to have a conversation that immediate self-forgiveness can come out. I'm wondering, have you seen this in your own life, Tyler, as somebody who studies apologies? Have you noticed that your own self-concept as a kind person or an empathetic person that this is sometimes perhaps kept you from apologizing or acknowledging harms that you have done?
没有人喜欢长期感觉不好。然后当有机会进行对话时，那种即时的自我宽恕就会显现出来。我想知道，泰勒，作为一名研究道歉的人，你在自己的生活中看到过这种情况吗？你有没有注意到你作为一个善良或善解人意的人的自我概念，有时或许让你无法道歉或承认你所造成的伤害？
Well, it's funny that you say that because I tend to think of myself as somebody who does apologize when I do things wrong, but then of course with the question I just asked previously, it also makes me think, oh, okay, so maybe I'm just a self-justifier, I can't actually see. Maybe I'm not good at apologies, I just think that I am because I'm that arrogant. I'm not quite sure which one it is. I want to just pause for one second and flag one thing, which is, it is the case
嗯，你说得很有趣，因为我倾向于认为自己是一个在做错事时会道歉的人，但当然，对于我刚才提出的问题，这也让我想到，哦，好吧，所以也许我只是一个自我辩护者，我实际上看不见。也许我不擅长道歉，我只是认为我擅长，因为我就是那么傲慢。我不确定到底是哪一个。我想暂停一秒钟并标记一件事，那就是，确实存在
that sometimes people, in fact, are accused of things by mistake or they're falsely accused of something. So, it cannot be that the only appropriate thing to do when you're accused of something is to apologize for it. We had a story on Hidden Brain a few months ago featuring a man named Fred Clay, who was charged and convicted of murder when he was a teenager, and he maintained his innocence and he said that he hadn't committed the crime. But when he was finally brought before the judge for sentencing, the fact that he did not
有时人们实际上是被错误地指控了，或者他们被虚假地指控了某事。所以，当你被指控某事时，唯一合适的做法不可能是道歉。几个月前，我们在《隐藏的大脑》中报道了一个名叫弗雷德·克莱的人的故事，他在十几岁时被指控并被判谋杀罪，他坚持自己的清白，并说他没有犯罪。但当他最终被带到法官面前接受判决时，他没有
express remorse, the fact that he did not apologize for what the court had convicted him of doing, that gave the judge reason to essentially lock him up and throw away the key. And as it turned out, Fred Clay spent several decades in prison, always maintaining his innocence, and finally, his trial was thrown out, and he was recently exonerated. And it just leads me to think that it cannot be that the answer to an accusation always is an apology. This is what makes it confusing. Sometimes, saying, I didn't do it, might actually be the the answer to an accusation always is an apology. This is what makes it confusing.
表达悔意，他没有为法院判决他所做的事情道歉，这给了法官理由基本上把他关起来并扔掉钥匙。事实证明，弗雷德·克莱在监狱里度过了几十年，一直坚持自己的清白，最终，他的审判被推翻，他最近被平反了。这让我觉得，对指控的回答不一定总是道歉。这就是让人困惑的地方。有时，说“我没做”可能实际上是回答指控的正确做法。这就是让人困惑的地方。
Sometimes, saying I didn't do it might actually be the right thing to say. Psychologically, we want to hear that the person that we're accusing is remorseful and that they admit what they've done is wrong. But you're right in that that's not always the case. And I think this is where the challenging situation that we tend to be in these days is that a lot of these sorts of cases are at least the ones that we read about
有时，说“我没做”可能实际上是正确的话。从心理学上讲，我们想听到我们指控的人感到悔恨，并且他们承认他们所做的是错误的。但你是对的，情况并非总是如此。我认为这就是我们这些天往往处于的挑战性境地，因为很多这类案件，至少是我们读到的那些
are quite high profile. And the accused individual is actually being in a way judged not just by the victim, but also by the court system, also by the media, also by the public,, also by the media, also by the public who consumes that media. And the reason why the media tends to pick these things up is because they are symbolic of a bigger problem, right? The George Floyd case was interesting to people
都是非常引人注目的。被指控的个人实际上不仅受到受害者的评判，还受到法院系统的评判，还受到媒体的评判，还受到消费该媒体的公众的评判。媒体倾向于报道这些事情的原因是它们象征着一个更大的问题，对吧？乔治·弗洛伊德案之所以引起人们的兴趣，
because it was about systemic racism. The Mitu movement, the media is interested because it's beyond that individual offender and victim. It becomes symbolic of the broader systemic problem. And they get judged on this, basically on this higher level. So let me see if I'm understanding what you're saying, Tyler. You're saying that in some of these cases, the cases themselves become a stand-in for
是因为它关乎系统性种族主义。媒体对“我也是”（Me Too）运动感兴趣，因为它超越了那个特定的违法者和受害者。它成为了更广泛的系统性问题的象征。他们基本上是在这个更高的层面上受到评判。那么让我看看我是否理解了你的意思，泰勒。你是说在其中一些案件中，案件本身成为了
something bigger than just the case itself. But if you're one of these individuals who gets caught up in one of these symbolic cases, it's perhaps understandable that you might say, hang on a second, don't put all of that on me. I'm just an individual here. This is just the fact of this case is all that we should be paying attention to, not sort of that grander, bigger symbolic story. That's right. In many of these situations, it's the historical problem that is being
比案件本身更大的东西的替代品。但如果你是这些卷入其中一个象征性案件的个人之一，或许可以理解你可能会说，等一下，不要把所有这些都压在我身上。我只是一个个体。这只是这个案件的事实，是我们应该关注的全部，而不是那种更宏大、更大的象征性故事。是的，没错。在许多这些情况下，是历史问题正在
tried, at least in the public's eyes. We hope that our court system can get past that and make it really about the individuals involved. But when things are being tried in the media, it really is that bigger symbolic meaning that is really driving the strength of people's reactions. So it's interesting these conversations are actually happening at multiple levels, right? So from a, when you have a police shooting, for example, the victim's family might say,
接受审判，至少在公众眼中是这样。我们希望我们的法院系统能够超越这一点，真正让它关乎所涉及的个人。但当事情在媒体上接受审判时，真正驱动人们反应强度的确实是那种更大的象征意义。所以有趣的是，这些对话实际上是在多个层面上进行的，对吧？所以，例如，当发生警察枪击事件时，受害者的家人可能会说，
this is part of a larger system of injustice that has existed for many years, many decades. From the point of view of the police officer who did the shooting, the police officer might say this was an individual case and we have to look at what the evidence says in this individual case. And the fact that one side is having a conversation about something that is structurally wrong and the other side is having an argument about an individual case. This might be part of the reason we often have mismatches in our public conversations about
这是多年、几十年来一直存在的更大不公正系统的一部分。从开枪警察的角度来看，警察可能会说这是一个个案，我们必须看看这个个案中的证据说明了什么。而一方在进行关于结构性错误的事情的对话，另一方在进行关于个案的争论。这可能是我们经常在关于这些案件的公共对话中出现错位的部分原因。
these cases. So, when the courts, for example, have exonerated police officers in some of these shootings, people feel, well, the courts now must be part of the problem as well, without necessarily taking into account that what the courts are set up to do is not, in some ways, try the symbolic case or the larger case, in some ways, try the symbolic case or the larger case, but essentially the facts of the very narrow case that's just in front of them. You know, in fact, we've done a little bit of research on this exact question.
这些案件。所以，例如，当法院在其中一些枪击事件中为警察平反时，人们会觉得，好吧，法院现在一定也是问题的一部分，而不一定考虑到法院设立的目的在某种程度上不是审判象征性案件或更大的案件，在某种程度上不是审判象征性案件或更大的案件，而是基本上审判摆在他们面前的非常狭窄的案件的事实。你知道，事实上，我们对这个问题做了一些研究。
We like to talk about it as the appraisal gap. What we tend to find is that when you're the member of a victim group, so when you're a woman seeing the Me Too situation unfold, when you're an African-American viewing the Black Lives Matter issues, that you see in that those individual cases, you see the systemic problem and as a consequence, the solution to those individual cases is a broader systemic solution. broader systemic solution. However, from the offender groups perspective, when I see something going wrong in my own group, then a bit of a self-protective mechanism here as well, tend to think of it as, okay, well, that's just a bad apple. And so what you tend to get as a gap between a victim group that believes that a systemic solution is necessary and really a group level apology for talking about apologies versus an offender group that doesn't necessarily believe that there's a systemic problem that believes that the right thing to do is to deal with the individual punish individual, and to have an individual level apology.
我们喜欢称之为评估差距。我们倾向于发现，当你是一个受害者群体的成员时，所以当你是一个看到“我也是”情况展开的女性，当你是一个观看“黑人的命也是命”问题的非裔美国人时，你在那些个案中看到了系统性问题，因此，解决这些个案的方案是一个更广泛的系统性方案。更广泛的系统性方案。然而，从违法者群体的角度来看，当我在我自己的群体中看到事情出错时，这里也有点自我保护机制，倾向于认为，好吧，那只是一个坏苹果。所以你倾向于得到的是一个受害者群体（认为需要系统性解决方案，并真正谈论群体层面的道歉）与一个违法者群体（不一定认为存在系统性问题，认为正确做法是处理个人、惩罚个人，并进行个人层面的道歉）之间的差距。
This is perhaps why group leaders sometimes come out and say that mistakes were made. Not, we collectively made a mistake. Clearly, mistakes were made. Mistakes were made here. And he's right, mistakes were made. Terrible mistakes were made. How do these mismatches and expectations
这或许就是为什么群体领导者有时会出来说“犯了错误”。而不是“我们集体犯了一个错误”。显然，犯了错误。这里犯了错误。他是对的，犯了错误。犯了可怕的错误。这些期望的错位如何
shape when apologies are demanded, how they are offered, and whether they are accepted? Tyler and other researchers have found that people nowadays increasingly have a greater appetite for apologies. We want to see people come forward and say, I'm sorry. But in an experiment, Tyler discovered something curious that comes about as a result of our heightened expectations for apologies. What we found is that the same individuals that thought it was really important to receive while at the same time decreasing their satisfaction when actually receiving it. I have to ask you though because I feel like I can see sort of a flip side to this which is that if we are as a society less accepting of apologies,
塑造道歉的需求、道歉的方式以及它们是否被接受？泰勒和其他研究人员发现，如今人们对道歉的渴望越来越大。我们想看到人们站出来说“对不起”。但在一个实验中，泰勒发现了一些奇怪的事情，这是由于我们对道歉的期望提高而产生的。我们发现，那些认为收到道歉非常重要的同一个人，在实际收到道歉时却降低了他们的满意度。但我必须问你，因为我觉得我可以看到这方面的一个反面，那就是如果我们作为一个社会对道歉的接受度较低，
in other words, someone comes forward, does the right thing, does the difficult thing, and apologizes, and we basically say, no thanks, that wasn't good enough. Doesn't that create a disincentive for people to actually apologize? And I feel like I see this in politicians increasingly when they're accused of things. They're increasingly saying the smart play here is in fact not to apologize because falling on your sword effectively accomplishes nothing. Is there a risk that in some ways are unwillingness to accept apologies can perversely cause us to actually receive fewer apologies? Yeah, that's a fair point. You know, if the purpose of an apology is to overcome
换句话说，有人站出来，做了正确的事，做了困难的事，并道歉了，而我们基本上说，不，谢谢，那还不够好。这难道不会产生一种阻止人们真正道歉的抑制作用吗？我觉得我在政治家身上越来越频繁地看到这一点，当他们被指控某事时。他们越来越说，这里的明智之举实际上是不道歉，因为引咎辞职实际上什么也完成不了。我们不愿接受道歉在某种程度上是否会反常地导致我们实际上收到更少的道歉？是的，这是一个合理的观点。你知道，如果道歉的目的是为了克服
the problem is to make the victim forgive you, Then yes, this does suggest that, you know, maybe the pay-offer in apology is not as great as we think it is. In fact, particularly in intergroup context, you know, these big systemic problems. We do tend to find that apologies for these big historical problems don't actually have that much of a positive impact on how the victim group feels and whether or not the victim group is willing to forgive. However, I suppose the other side of this is that that's assuming that the particular outcome is the purpose of an apology. So if the purpose of an apology is to get forgiveness, is to make the other person feel better
问题是为了让受害者原谅你，那么是的，这确实表明，你知道，也许道歉的回报并不像我们想象的那么大。事实上，特别是在群体间背景下，你知道，这些大的系统性问题。我们确实倾向于发现，对这些重大历史问题的道歉实际上对受害者群体的感受以及受害者群体是否愿意原谅并没有太大的积极影响。然而，我想这方面的另一面是，这假设特定的结果是道歉的目的。所以如果道歉的目的是为了获得宽恕，是为了让对方感觉更好
and to feel better as yourself, then yes, they are losing their power. Right. If the purpose of the apology is because it's the right thing to do, because it makes you better as a person, because it makes our society better. If that's the purpose of an apology, then it doesn't matter whether or not it follows with forgiveness or it follows with reduction in sentencing or if it follows in reduction of your feelings of guilt, it's still the right thing to do. It's hard to admit that we're wrong. It's easy to feel our own pain, but much harder to see the pain we cause others. The psychological barriers to apologizing make it easier for all of us to
并让自己感觉更好，那么是的，它们正在失去力量。对。如果道歉的目的是因为它是一件正确的事，因为它让你作为一个更好的人，因为它让我们的社会变得更好。如果这就是道歉的目的，那么它是否伴随着宽恕，或者它是否伴随着减刑，或者它是否伴随着你罪恶感的减轻，这并不重要，它仍然是正确的事。承认我们错了很难。感受我们自己的痛苦很容易，但看到我们给他人造成的痛苦却难得多。道歉的心理障碍使我们所有人更容易
ignore and justify and minimize wrongdoing. When we come back, why it makes sense to apologize even when forgiveness might not be forthcoming? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We've talked about some of the internal and external obstacles to apologizing. Why non-apologizing can sometimes feel good? And how admitting that we've done someone wrong can threaten our positive view of ourselves. And we've looked at the gaps in perception between victims and transgressors that can cause apologies, even genuine apologies, to be ignored or dismissed.
忽视、辩解和最小化不当行为。当我们回来时，为什么即使宽恕可能不会到来，道歉也是有意义的？你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。我们已经谈到了一些道歉的内部和外部障碍。为什么不道歉有时会感觉良好？以及承认我们做错了某事如何威胁我们对自己积极的看法。我们已经审视了受害者和违法者之间感知上的差距，这些差距可能导致道歉，即使是真诚的道歉，也被忽视或驳回。
At the University of Queensland in Australia, psychologist Tyler Okimoto does more than explore all the ways apologies don't work or can go wrong He also looks at when apologies work how to apologize better and why we should Tyler you ran an experiment that measured how likely people were to think an apology was genuine and you found a connection With the expression of remorse. Can you tell me what you found? You know one of the things that people are really looking for in a apology is a sincere belief that the individual who's apologizing is remorseful for their actions. In fact, judgments of remorse and sincerity of that remorse are really influential in changing whether or
在澳大利亚昆士兰大学，心理学家泰勒·奥基莫托所做的不仅仅是探索道歉不起作用或可能出错的所有方式。他还研究道歉何时起作用，如何更好地道歉，以及为什么我们应该这样做。泰勒，你进行了一项实验，测量人们认为道歉是真诚的可能性，你发现了一个联系，与悔意的表达有关。你能告诉我你发现了什么吗？你知道，人们在道歉中真正寻找的一件事是真诚地相信道歉的人对他们的行为感到悔恨。事实上，对悔意的判断以及这种悔意的真诚度在改变人们是否
not people are willing to forgive after an apology. What kind of expressions of remorse did you study? So we looked at a bunch of different sorts of expressions. You know, we looked at traditional apologies. So the words that people say and the meaning behind them. We also looked at physical displays, things like tears, things like your body posture, in a way, those nonverbal gestures are apparently a little bit involuntary. And so when you see individuals seeming to lose control with their emotions, with their feelings of remorse and regret, then it signals to us that what they're saying is actually
愿意在道歉后原谅方面确实很有影响力。你研究了什么样的悔意表达？所以我们研究了一堆不同种类的表达。你知道，我们研究了传统的道歉。所以人们说的话以及它们背后的含义。我们还研究了身体展示，比如眼泪，比如你的身体姿势，在某种程度上，那些非语言手势显然有点不由自主。所以当你看到个人似乎失去了对情绪、对悔恨和遗憾感的控制时，那么它就向我们发出信号，表明他们所说的话实际上是
true. In fact, it's so true that they're losing control, they're crying, they're flopping over in just your submission. So that's what makes a good apology is all of the pieces around it, not just the words themselves. I'm thinking of a study by Alison Woodbroke who examined apologies at parole hearings for crimes ranging from speeding to murder. And she found apologies with a promise of good future behavior were more effective, whereas apologies had included an explanation of why the transgression occurred tended to be ineffective. What is that telling us,
真实的。事实上，它是如此真实，以至于他们失去了控制，他们在哭泣，他们在你的顺从面前倒下。所以这就是好的道歉的全部组成部分，不仅仅是话语本身。我想到艾丽森·伍德布鲁克的一项研究，她检查了从超速到谋杀等各种犯罪的假释听证会上的道歉。她发现带有未来良好行为承诺的道歉更有效，而包含对违规发生原因解释的道歉往往无效。这告诉我们什么，
Tyler? That finding is actually quite consistent with what we find in the psychology literature. There's really two aspects to the reconciliation process. There's the backward looking, trying to make sense and come to a shared understanding about what happened, trying to understand the other person's perspective on what happened, trying to share your own perspective on what happened, and come to some agreement about what the offense was itself and what my responsibility was in that. Then the other half of it is a forward thinking, the future focused aspect of the apology, which is really what's going to happen from now on.
泰勒？这一发现实际上与我们在心理学文献中发现的内容非常一致。和解过程确实有两个方面。一个是回顾过去，试图理解并就发生的事情达成共识，试图理解对方对发生的事情的看法，试图分享你自己对发生的事情的看法，并就违规本身是什么以及我在其中承担的责任达成某种协议。然后另一半是前瞻性，道歉中面向未来的方面，这实际上是今后会发生什么。
What people are often looking for is a promise of future behavior and some action that begins to evidence your willingness to move towards that future behavior. The research of Cindy France found that apologizing too early can make apologies less effective. What's going on here, Tyler? If you apologize in a knee jerk sort of way, then it really does come off like a knee jerk apology. But at the same time, if you do delay too long, and then apologize later on down the track, it really comes off as, oh well, you know, they tried to get away with not apologizing.
人们通常寻找的是未来行为的承诺和一些开始证明你愿意朝着那个未来行为迈进的行动。辛迪·弗朗斯的研究发现，道歉太早会使道歉效果降低。这里发生了什么，泰勒？如果你以一种膝跳反应的方式道歉，那么它确实看起来像是一种膝跳道歉。但与此同时，如果你延迟太久，然后在以后道歉，它确实看起来像是，哦，好吧，你知道，他们试图逃避不道歉。
But then finally cave to the pressure. And so there does seem to be some sweet spot about where the apology should occur. In some of the research that we've done, we actually looked at this timing pattern within intergroup apologies. And what we found is this problem with delays to where if you wait too long, it comes off as cold and calculated and insincere and you only did it because you had to. But we did find a little bit of an antidote.
但最终屈服于压力。所以道歉应该在什么时候发生似乎确实有一个最佳点。在我们所做的一些研究中，我们实际上研究了群体间道歉中的这种时间模式。我们发现的是延迟带来的问题，如果你等得太久，它看起来既冷漠又经过计算且不真诚，而且你这样做只是因为你不得不这样做。但我们确实发现了一点解药。
If the offender group, the transgressor group is using that time for something positive, is using that time to reflect, then that delay can actually turn out to be a good thing. Right, so for example, if in the apology, you say, I know it's been a few weeks, the reason why we took that time is because we wanted to really understand the victims and really speak with them to recognize and understand their perspectives before we could
如果违法者群体、违规者群体利用这段时间做一些积极的事情，利用这段时间进行反思，那么这种延迟实际上可能变成一件好事。对，所以例如，如果在道歉中，你说，我知道已经过去几周了，我们花那段时间的原因是因为我们想真正理解受害者并真正与他们交谈，以在我们可以
make an appropriate response. So in that sense, then that delay can be a good thing. But in absence of that, in absence of an explanation, then it can be problematic. It's really interesting, Tyler, because as you're talking, I'm seeing how complex this issue is, because the line between what makes sense and what's effective and what's ineffective is actually quite thin, right? So in other words, on the one hand, apologizing to soon can be a problem and apologizing too late can be a problem, and apologizing too late can be a problem. Some researchers found that when you justify
做出适当回应之前承认并理解他们的观点。所以从这个意义上说，这种延迟可能是一件好事。但如果没有这一点，如果没有解释，那么它可能会有问题。这真的很有趣，泰勒，因为当你说话时，我看到了这个问题有多复杂，因为什么是有意义的、什么是有效的和什么是无效的之间的界限实际上非常薄，对吧？所以换句话说，一方面，道歉太早可能是一个问题，道歉太晚可能是一个问题，道歉太晚可能是一个问题。一些研究人员发现，当你辩解时
or explain your behavior and talk about your intentions and say that I actually didn't mean to do this, that can have a bad effect, and other research suggests that it actually is helpful to put context to the situation and say, this is not what I intended to do. I know that I caused harm, but that it was not my intention. It almost feels like it's, for every argument you can make about what makes a good apology, there's another piece
或者解释你的行为，谈论你的意图，并说我其实不是故意的，这可能会产生负面影响。而其他研究表明，为情况提供背景说明并说“这不是我的本意”实际上是有帮助的。我知道我造成了伤害，但那并非我的本意。这感觉就像是，你每提出一个关于什么才是好的道歉的论点，就会有另一项研究
of research that basically says you have to do precisely the opposite. Yeah, well, it is complicated. In fact, this is why I personally find it so interesting and challenging is because it's sufficiently complex that there is no formula You know, there's writing out there that will say to have an effective apology You need these five things or you need the seven steps to this that might be true in a general sense
基本上说你必须做完全相反的事情。是的，这很复杂。事实上，这就是为什么我个人觉得它如此有趣且具有挑战性，因为它足够复杂，没有固定的公式。你知道，外面有很多文章会说，要进行有效的道歉，你需要这五件事或那七个步骤，这在一般意义上可能是对的，
but every situation is different and The same apology the same structure of apology the same components are not going to be similarly effective in all situations. It also means that you need to, you know, once you've apologized, you also need to reflect a little bit. Maybe it wasn't good enough. If you apologize and it's not accepted, try to learn from that, try to understand what it is that is needed, try to understand the other person's perspective or the other group's perspective. It's interesting because I think when we see people sort of revising their apologies, our instinct is often to say, well, this person is just, you know, caving to pressure, or they're basically, you know, they're finally being brought to their senses to do what they should have done in the first place. But I suppose a more compassionate way to look at it is to say that sometimes it does take people
但每种情况都不同，同样的道歉、同样的道歉结构、同样的组成部分在所有情况下都不会同样有效。这也意味着你需要，你知道，一旦你道歉了，你也需要稍微反思一下。也许它还不够好。如果你道歉了但没有被接受，试着从中学习，试着理解需要什么，试着理解对方或对方群体的视角。这很有趣，因为我认为当我们看到人们修改他们的道歉时，我们的直觉往往是说，这个人只是，你知道，屈服于压力，或者他们基本上，你知道，终于清醒过来去做他们本该做的事情。但我认为，一种更具同情心的看法是说，有时人们确实需要
some time to actually understand what they have done. And in some ways, the fact that people are revising their positions should not be seen as a bad thing, it might actually maybe we should say it as a good thing. Yeah, that's right. In fact, some of the research that we're doing currently is really looking at diets, so a victim and a fender diet and trying to understand
一些时间来真正理解他们所做的事情。在某种程度上，人们正在修改他们的立场这一事实不应被视为一件坏事，也许我们应该把它看作是一件好事。是的，没错。事实上，我们目前正在进行的一些研究确实是在观察二元关系，即受害者和加害者的二元关系，并试图理解
how the apology and the forgiveness go together. And what we're actually finding is that we tend to think about these things as, you know, something's done wrong, you apologize, you forgive, and then everyone, you know, shake hands and moves on. In reality, how these things evolve over time is that something's done wrong. You know, the victim expresses the needs that they have in the situation.
道歉和宽恕是如何结合在一起的。我们实际上发现，我们倾向于认为这些事情是，你知道，某事做错了，你道歉，你宽恕，然后每个人，你知道，握手言和，继续前进。实际上，这些事情随着时间的推移是如何演变的，是某事做错了。你知道，受害者表达了他们在这种情况下的需求。
The offender tries to respond with something resembling an apology. The victim then reacts to that. And then, of course, the offender then revises what they've said. And so really reconciliation is an unfolding process that's about what's going on inside the offender's head as well as what they're communicating, but also what's going on inside the victim's head and what it is that they're communicating as well. It's so interesting. We spoke with the psychologist Shadid Whitfleet last week and she was talking about the psychology of forgiveness, and she said
加害者试图用类似道歉的话语来回应。受害者随后对此做出反应。然后，当然，加害者随后修改了他们所说的话。所以，和解实际上是一个展开的过程，它既关乎加害者头脑中正在发生的事情以及他们正在传达的内容，也关乎受害者头脑中正在发生的事情以及他们正在传达的内容。这太有趣了。我们上周采访了心理学家沙迪德·惠特弗利特，她谈到了宽恕的心理学，她说
almost something eerily similar to what you're saying, which is that forgiveness is not typically a one-off decision. Someone says something to you, you say, okay, I forgive you, and case closed and we all move on, but it's much more of this unfolding dance, if you will, that involves often multiple steps of back and forth, and often unfolds over a long period of time. Yeah, that's right. Sometimes you don't know what the victims needs are. And so the offender also needs to engage in that process to understand what the issues are and how to best respond to them. If I give my own conversations with my wife, you know, sometimes I don't understand why she's upset about something. And so my apology might not be appropriate.
几乎和你所说的一模一样，那就是宽恕通常不是一个一次性的决定。某人对你说些什么，你说，好吧，我原谅你，然后案件结束，我们都继续前进，但这更像是一种展开的舞蹈，如果你愿意的话，它通常涉及多个来回的步骤，并且通常在很长一段时间内展开。是的，没错。有时你不知道受害者的需求是什么。因此，加害者也需要参与到那个过程中，以了解问题所在以及如何最好地回应它们。如果我以我和我妻子的对话为例，你知道，有时我不明白她为什么对某事感到不安。所以我的道歉可能不合适。
It's really through that conversation and that understanding over time that we come to realize why it is that the other person is really upset. And only then can we respond in a way that is appropriate for their needs in the situation. I want to talk a moment about collective apologies and apologies on a larger scale. On January 30th, 1972, British paratroopers opened fire on protesters in Northern Ireland and they killed 13 protesters. The event came to be known as Bloody Sunday. 38 years later, the British Prime Minister David Cameron offered the following apology.
正是通过那种对话和随着时间的推移而产生的理解，我们才意识到为什么对方真的感到不安。只有这样，我们才能以适合他们需求的方式做出回应。我想花点时间谈谈集体道歉和更大规模的道歉。1972年1月30日，英国伞兵在北爱尔兰向抗议者开火，杀死了13名抗议者。这一事件后来被称为“血腥星期日”。38年后，英国首相戴维·卡梅伦发表了以下道歉。
I never want to believe anything bad about our country. I never want to call into question the behaviour of our soldiers and our army who I believe to be the finest in the world. But the conclusions of this report are absolutely clear. What happened on bloody Sunday was both o'r ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdr yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r yw'r y The government is ultimately responsible for the conduct of the armed forces, and for that, on behalf of the government, indeed on behalf of our country, I am deeply sorry. So Tyler, you've cited the speech as a powerful example of a great apology. What do you think makes it effective? The sincerity that you can hear in David Cameron's voice, the words in fully accepting responsibility, it was particularly powerful, I think, because he was speaking out in a way against the opinions and views of past political leaders,
我从不想相信关于我们国家的任何坏事。我从不想质疑我们士兵和军队的行为，我认为他们是世界上最优秀的。但这份报告的结论是绝对明确的。血腥星期日发生的事情既是……（此处原文重复，省略）……政府最终要对武装部队的行为负责，为此，我代表政府，确实代表我们的国家，深表歉意。那么泰勒，你引用了这段演讲作为一个伟大道歉的有力例子。你认为是什么让它有效？你在戴维·卡梅伦的声音中能听到的真诚，完全承担责任的言辞，我认为它特别有力，因为他以一种反对过去政治领导人观点和看法的方式发表了讲话，
to say that, no, no, we've actually looked at it, and we are coming to terms with the fact that there is responsibility here that needs to be accounted for. Yeah, I'm sort of, I'm not hearing minimization, I'm not hearing dodging, I'm not hearing hedging, I'm not hearing, well, I'm sorry if you felt bad about this, even though, you know, I don't think there was anything wrong that was done, I'm not hearing any of those things in this apology. The people that analyze these sorts of statements from a discourse perspective really talk about the Blaysunday apology of David Cameron's, as really a top 10 apology ever given in history. So in that sense, the words themselves are really on point.
说，不，不，我们实际上已经审视了它，我们正在接受这样一个事实，即这里有需要承担的责任。是的，我没有听到淡化，我没有听到回避，我没有听到推诿，我没有听到，嗯，如果你对此感到难过我很抱歉，尽管，你知道，我不认为有什么做错的地方，在这个道歉中我没有听到任何这些东西。那些从话语角度分析这类声明的人确实将戴维·卡梅伦的血腥星期日道歉视为历史上排名前十的道歉。所以从这个意义上说，这些话本身确实切中要害。
Yeah. I want to play another clip of another famous apology. This one was from Ronald Reagan in 1988. Members of Congress and distinguished guests, we gather here today to write a grave wrong. More than 40 years ago, shortly after the bombing of Pearl Harbor, 120,000 persons of Japanese ancestry living in the United States were forcibly removed from their homes and placed in makeshift internment camps. This action was taken without trial, without jury. It was based solely on race, for these 120,000 were Americans of Japanese descent.
是的。我想播放另一个著名道歉的片段。这是罗纳德·里根在1988年的讲话。国会议员和尊贵的客人们，我们今天聚集在这里是为了纠正一个严重的错误。40多年前，在珍珠港事件后不久，12万名居住在美国的日裔被强行从家中带走，安置在临时的拘留营中。这一行动是在没有审判、没有陪审团的情况下采取的。它完全基于种族，因为这12万人是日裔美国人。
Yes, the nation was then at war, struggling for its survival, and it's not for us today to pass judgment upon those who may have made mistakes while engaged in that great struggle. Yet we must recognize that the internment of Japanese Americans was just that, a mistake. For throughout the war, Japanese Americans in the tens of thousands remained utterly loyal to the United States. So, Tyner, talk about this apology in the context of the one we heard from David Cameron. As I'm listening to it, I realized that it surely must help that the person making the apology is not the one who was responsible for the wrongdoing.
是的，当时国家处于战争状态，为生存而挣扎，我们今天不应去评判那些在参与那场伟大斗争时可能犯错的人。然而，我们必须承认，对日裔美国人的拘留正是如此，一个错误。因为在整个战争期间，成千上万的日裔美国人对美国保持着绝对的忠诚。那么，泰勒，请谈谈这个道歉，结合我们从戴维·卡梅伦那里听到的那个。当我听它的时候，我意识到，做出道歉的人不是那个对错误负责的人，这肯定会有所帮助。
David Cameron didn't order bloody Sunday. Ronald Reagan didn't order the internment of Japanese Americans during World War II, it certainly seems easier to apologize when you are not the person who is actually responsible for the harm. Yes, you know, and a lot of these big historical transgressions aren't spoken about until generations later in the majority of cases. You know. This particular example that you're raising is somewhat personal to myself
戴维·卡梅伦没有下令血腥星期日。罗纳德·里根没有下令在二战期间拘留日裔美国人，当你不是那个真正对伤害负责的人时，道歉似乎确实更容易。是的，你知道，在大多数情况下，许多这些重大的历史过错直到几代人之后才被谈论。你知道。你提出的这个特定例子对我个人来说有些亲近，
and that my lost name's Okomoto and I'm fourth generation American. And so I had relatives that not were in turn, but were told to leave California on threat of internment. And the same thing is true, I guess, on the victim side in that as a descendant of somebody that would have been affected by this decision, it's also easier for me as an individual to get to that point of forgiveness because there is some distance.
因为我的姓氏是冈本，我是第四代美国人。所以我有一些亲戚没有被拘留，但被告知在拘留的威胁下离开加利福尼亚。我想在受害者这一边也是一样，作为一个本会受到这个决定影响的人的后代，作为个人，我更容易达到宽恕的那一点，因为有一定的距离。
And a really abstraction of the problem. It's a lot easier to see other perspectives when you have some distance either for you temporally or in this case generationally. Yeah, and so it's really not surprising that it you know sometimes takes decades for states governments to understand What is needed in that situation and in fact? I you know really takes time we look at slavery as another example and in fact, it really takes time. We look at slavery as another example. Certain parts of the government have apologized for that,
以及对问题的真正抽象化。当你无论是从时间上还是在这种情况下从代际上有一点距离时，更容易看到其他视角。是的，所以这真的不足为奇，你知道，有时国家政府需要几十年才能理解在那种情况下需要什么，事实上，我，你知道，确实需要时间。我们以奴隶制为例，事实上，它确实需要时间。我们以奴隶制为例。政府的某些部分已经为此道歉了，
but not all parts of the government. In Australia, Tyler says the government has denoted a national day of repentance. It's called, sorry day. The idea is to apologize to Aboriginal people who had their children stolen from them over multiple decades in the 20th century. The abductions were carried out to assimilate children into mainstream white culture. The hurt, the humiliation, the degradation, and the sheer brutality of the act of physically separating a mother from her children
但并非政府的所有部分。在澳大利亚，泰勒说政府已经指定了一个全国忏悔日。它被称为“道歉日”。其理念是向那些在20世纪几十年里孩子被偷走的土著人民道歉。这些绑架是为了将儿童同化进主流白人文化。那种伤害、羞辱、退化，以及将母亲与孩子身体分离的行为所带来的纯粹残暴，
is a deeper salt on our senses and on our most elemental humanity. Tyler has studied the effects of public demonstrations of remorse by ordinary Australians. The research that we've done on this is actually pointed to the fact that that sorry demonstration is really important, while government apologies are great. From the victims group perspective, what people want from the apology from these collective problems is really a belief that the offending group as a whole is remorseful. And so when you get thousands of people marching in the streets, saying how sorry they are for what happened, that's actually quite impactful,
是对我们感官和我们最基本人性的更深层打击。泰勒研究了普通澳大利亚人公开表达悔意的效果。我们对此所做的研究实际上指出，那种道歉的展示确实很重要，虽然政府的道歉很好。从受害者群体的角度来看，人们从这些集体问题的道歉中真正想要的是一种信念，即加害群体作为一个整体是悔恨的。所以当你看到成千上万的人走上街头，说他们对发生的事情感到多么抱歉时，那实际上是相当有影响力的，
relative to just some politician who's getting up there and saying something for possibly political reasons. It's an acknowledgement of the wrongdoing that was committed to the stolen generations. It's something that needs to be remembered by everyone. It's an atrocity that happened in Australia's history. And for a non-indigenous person to learn a little bit, you know, history about that, it will show, yeah, we mean a lot to an Aboriginal person. Yeah. It can help our people heal. You know, you hinted at something earlier in our conversation
相对于仅仅是某个政客站出来，可能出于政治原因说些什么。这是对被偷走的一代所犯下的错误的一种承认。这是每个人都需要记住的事情。这是澳大利亚历史上发生的一场暴行。对于一个非土著人来说，了解一点关于那段历史，你知道，它会表明，是的，我们对土著人意义重大。是的。它可以帮助我们的人民治愈。你知道，你在我们谈话的早些时候暗示了一些事情，
tighter that I want to come back to, which is one reason to pursue apologies might not be necessarily because they have this instrumental effect on generating forgiveness. Because as we've seen, sometimes apologies are not crafted correctly. Sometimes the victims might not be in a position to hear the apology. Sometimes the apology might be insufficient to the harm
泰勒，我想回到这一点，即追求道歉的一个原因可能不一定是因为它们在产生宽恕方面具有这种工具性效果。因为正如我们所见，有时道歉制作得不正确。有时受害者可能处于无法听到道歉的位置。有时道歉可能不足以弥补所造成的伤害。
that was done. There are all kinds of ways these misunderstandings could occur. But one idea that you hinted at that's really important is that our reluctance to offer apologies often comes down to protecting the self, whereas our willingness to offer apologies often comes down to our interest in protecting relationships. Can you talk about this distinction that in some ways the reason to offer apologies might not necessarily be because they're going to generate a forgiveness or get the answer
这些误解可能以各种方式发生。但你暗示的一个非常重要的观点是，我们不愿道歉往往归结为保护自我，而我们愿意道歉往往归结为我们保护关系的兴趣。你能谈谈这种区别吗？即在某种程度上，提供道歉的原因可能不一定是因为它们会产生宽恕或得到答案，
that we want, but in some ways because you're trying to repair a bond that is afraid or broken. There's really two sides, two big elements, to what is lost in a transgression. So on the one hand, a transgression threatens the relationship that threatens your shared identity, you know, who you are, you know, for talking about close relationships, who are you, who you are as a couple, the values that you shared. On the other side, it also does threaten that status and power kind of hierarchy. So a transgression demeans the other party. It undermines them, it removes control.
我们想要的，但在某种程度上是因为你试图修复一段破裂或受损的关系。在过错中失去的东西确实有两个方面，两个大要素。一方面，过错威胁到了关系，威胁到了你们共同的身份，你知道，你们是谁，你知道，如果我们谈论亲密关系，你们是谁，你们作为一对伴侣是谁，你们共享的价值观。另一方面，它也确实威胁到了那种地位和权力的等级制度。所以过错贬低了另一方。它削弱了他们，剥夺了控制权。
And so from an apology standpoint, apologies is a kind of a response to that loss, are an attempt to recover either one of those pillars. So apologies can help to rebuild the relationship, reestablish the agreement, what the relationship is based on, or they can transmit power and control to the other party. They give the other party the option to forgive. They communicate that degrading you was the wrong thing to do. The apology is often the starting point to the conversation. Now that you've actually admitted that something is wrong, now we can talk about the right
因此，从道歉的角度来看，道歉是对那种损失的一种回应，是试图恢复那两个支柱之一。所以道歉可以帮助重建关系，重新建立协议，即关系的基础，或者它们可以向另一方传递权力和控制权。它们给了另一方宽恕的选择。它们传达了贬低你是错误的行为。道歉往往是对话的起点。既然你已经承认某事是错误的，现在我们可以谈谈正确的
way to move forward. And so it's perhaps not surprising that victim groups are not immediately forgiving in the face of an apology because the apology is an opening and it's the first step in moving forward towards real reconciliation. One of the things that I think I'm really struck by is an echo I'm hearing in what you're saying and what we heard from the psychologist Charlotte Whitfield last week. We talked with her about the challenges of forgiveness and how it's often difficult to forgive and sometimes we look for forgiveness in our hearts and don't find it or we wait
前进方式。所以受害者群体在面对道歉时不会立即宽恕也就不足为奇了，因为道歉是一个开端，是迈向真正和解的第一步。我认为让我印象深刻的一件事是我在你所说的话中听到的回声，以及我们上周从心理学家夏洛特·惠特菲尔德那里听到的。我们和她谈到了宽恕的挑战，以及宽恕往往是多么困难，有时我们在心中寻找宽恕却找不到，或者我们等待
until we receive the right apology and often that apology is not forthcoming. And what you're saying of course is the mirror image of that which is that you might come up with a beautiful apology, the right apology, but maybe the victim is not ready to hear it. And maybe it actually is going to fall on deaf ears, and maybe you're not going to get the reconciliation that you seek. And I think a common thread that connects these two veins of research is perhaps the importance of thinking about both forgiveness and apologies as gifts, gifts that we give one another without
直到我们收到正确的道歉，而这种道歉往往不会到来。而你所说的当然是它的镜像，即你可能会想出一个美丽的道歉，正确的道歉，但也许受害者还没有准备好听到它。也许它实际上会充耳不闻，也许你不会得到你寻求的和解。我认为连接这两条研究脉络的一条共同线索，也许是思考将宽恕和道歉都视为礼物的重要性，我们彼此给予的礼物，没有
an expectation of reciprocation. What do you make of that idea, Tyler? A number of psychologists have really conceptualized apologies as a gift that comes without expectation. And I think that there's something really important in that, thinking about apologies not as a linear progression, but really as a offering, as a gesture that is unconditional is probably good for getting them to have positive effects both on the victim as well as on your relationship. I asked Titer whether he had ever failed to apologize to someone he cared about. He thought about it a moment and then mentioned his 10-year-old daughter Abigail. He said he sometimes loses his temper with her and then fails to apologize to her.
回报的期望。泰勒，你对这个想法有什么看法？许多心理学家确实将道歉概念化为一种没有期望的礼物。我认为这其中有一些非常重要的东西，将道歉视为不是线性的进展，而真正作为一种奉献，作为一种无条件的姿态，可能对让它们在受害者以及你们的关系上产生积极影响是有好处的。我问泰勒他是否曾经没有向他在乎的人道歉。他想了一会儿，然后提到了他10岁的女儿阿比盖尔。他说他有时会对她发脾气，然后没有向她道歉。
I asked him what he would tell Abigail if she were listening. Well, this actually sounds like one of our experiments where we get people to reflect on a time they didn't apologize. And so I suppose it's a fair question because I subject other people to go through this process, which is actually quite difficult. So if I was to offer an apology to my daughter, I'll probably go something like this Abigail, you know, I realized that what I said and how really how I said it was a bit over the top.
我问他如果阿比盖尔在听，他会告诉她什么。嗯，这听起来确实像我们的实验之一，我们让人们反思他们没有道歉的时候。所以我认为这是一个公平的问题，因为我让其他人经历这个过程，这实际上是相当困难的。所以如果我要向我的女儿道歉，我可能会这样说：阿比盖尔，你知道，我意识到我所说的话以及我真正说它的方式有点过分了。
I was really frustrated and angry at the time, which was probably not the right state of mine to be in when parenting. And you know, I recognize that the choice that I made to respond in that way is really hurtful to you. It probably doesn't do great things for our relationship. And I promise to do my best to be better. Even the future, I do fly off the handle. Feel free to give me the signal that I have done such. I'm sure your mother will help as well.
我当时真的很沮丧和生气，这可能不是为人父母时应有的正确心态。而且你知道，我承认我选择以那种方式回应确实伤害了你。它可能对我们的关系没有好处。我承诺尽我所能做得更好。即使将来，我确实发火了。请随时给我信号，表明我已经这样做了。我相信你妈妈也会帮忙的。
And it's something that I'm committed to improving because I know that it's what's best for our relationship. Tyler Okimoto is a psychologist at the University of Queensland in Australia. Tyler, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. No worries at all, Shankar. Thank you for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Kristen Wong, Laura Correll, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
这是我致力于改进的事情，因为我知道这对我们的关系最好。泰勒·冈本是澳大利亚昆士兰大学的心理学家。泰勒，非常感谢你今天参加我的节目《隐藏的大脑》。不用客气，尚卡尔。谢谢你邀请我。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·科雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。
Our run sun hero today is Johanna Ramos Boyer. Over the past few months, Johanna has helped me coordinate interviews that I've done about my new book, Useful Delusions. In a time when all of our interviews were happening on Zoom or other video conferencing platforms, it was a great help to know that Johanna was on top of every detail so that I could focus on the conversations. Thank you so much Johanna. If you love Hidden Brain, you're going to love our newsletter. Sign up for updates on interesting research that affects your life, the weekly puzzle,
我们今天的无名英雄是乔安娜·拉莫斯·博耶。在过去的几个月里，乔安娜帮助我协调了我关于我的新书《有用的错觉》的采访。在所有采访都在Zoom或其他视频会议平台上进行的时候，知道乔安娜处理了每一个细节，让我能够专注于对话，这对我帮助很大。非常感谢你，乔安娜。如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》，你会喜欢我们的时事通讯。注册以获取影响你生活的有趣研究的更新，每周的谜题，
and a moment of joy. Go to news.hiddenbrain.org. That's N-E-W-S dot hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及片刻的快乐。访问 news.hiddenbrain.org。那是 N-E-W-S 点 hiddenbrain 点 org。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。